gilbert thanks Chris now when Gary and I
launched our Kickstarter for a new
pointed click adventure game we had two
goals in mind the first was for you to
play a truly classic graphic adventure
and the second was for us to relive the
nostalgia of making one of those games
again and now with the dedication of
Microsoft thimble we park is going to be
coming to Windows 10 and Xbox one and
here is a quick preview a thimble we
park with pixels so sharp they could
poke your eye out
so good thanks a lot Ron when we
announced Xbox game preview at e3 we had
an outpouring of interest from the
development community who are excited to
have players experience their games and
provide feedback before their full
release two games have released through
the program so far and we're excited to
announce it sheltered team 17s
post-apocalyptic family bomb shelter
simulator is going to be available for
download later today also coming soon is
a really cool dinosaur survival title
Ark survival evolved it's going to be
coming to game preview this winter in
shipping next year on Xbox one in
Windows 10 let's take a look
you
alright